hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar the
importance of liquid biopsy
msi for studying tumors and
immunotherapy applications
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker paul r
walker md facp
chief medical officer circulogene
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr walker you
may now begin your presentation
thank you it is a delight to be able to
present today
on the importance of liquid biopsy
microsatellite instability for the study
of tumors and immunotherapy applications
we are in the midst of a remarkably
transformative era of treating cancer
with precision
molecular oncology and immunotherapy
with immune checkpoint blockade and what
is
really exciting is for the first time
we're just not making small strides of
improvement but we're getting
extended survival with targeted
therapies in immunotherapy
and beginning to elevate the cancer
survival
curve to the point of curability across
even metastatic solid tumors what is
vital in this new era of treating cancer
is the evolving technology of liquid
biopsies
with plasma next generation sequencing
to assess for circulating tumor dna and
rna
and now we have that capab same
capability to test for
microsatellite in instability
this is the thermal fissure disclosure
slide for my talk
in medicine we can always learn from the
past to better the
the future it was in 1966 when henry
lynch first published the lynch syndrome
of familial cancers when he went
through pedigrees of families with
clusters of cancers
it was not until three decades later
that the underlying cause of these
cluster of hereditary cancers
the that made up the lynch syndrome was
identified
with the micro satellite instability due
to
dna mismatch repaired deficiency
that was three decades ago where have we
come
over the past three three decades to
where we are
today
from the lynch syndrome of of 30 years
ago
colon cancer has led the development
over these past
three decades to give us better
understanding
and better treatment of msi cancers
we now know that micro satellite
instability can be
germline in the lynch syndrome with
germline mutations in mlh1 and msh2
dominating with the whole host of
cancers below the diaphragm and even in
the central nervous system
but it can also be sporadic such that 10
percent of colon cancers
will be sporadically msi high due to
epigenetic
mlh1 silencing
but it's also clear that we now know
msi high cancers are not just limited to
the lynch syndrome it's beyond
colorectal and endometrial
it can extend across the any type of
solid
tumor small bowel very frequently
adrenal corticocarcinomas very
frequently but across the whole spectrum
of all cancers and the fact that it's
not limited just to one cancer
is clearly indicating that msi high
cancers have a unique
tumor biology
it is important to understand this tumor
biology it is important to study this
tumor biology
because that is how there will be better
treatment of the
unique tumor biology of msi high cancers
with the msi high cancers
the alteration in the size of the
microsatellites will
increase the neoantigens this very
frequently is associated with an overall
increased tumor mutation burden such as
75
of msi high cancers will also be tumor
mutation burden
high but most tmb high cancers are not
msi high this is a venn diagram of a
multitude of cancers
looking at microsatellite instability to
a mutational burden
and pdo1 expression and msi high and tmb
are intimately related but pdl1
expression is not related to the msi
high cancers overall
what we have learned from the msi high
cancers
tumor micro environment by looking at
the
tissue is that they are enriched with
tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes tills and the m1
macrophages which improve the survival
and msi high
rectal cancers but there's also an
association
with immune checkpoints compared to
microsatellites stable colorectal
cancers msi high
colorectal cancers will
express pd1 pdo1 and ctla4
and what is now so important is that
these can be
inhibited which really indicates that
immune therapy
has a strong basis to be very effective
in
msi high cancers
but it's more to it than just just the
tmb and the immune checkpoints there can
be a variety of resistant
pathways there there could be mutations
in beta-2 microglobulin and mhc-1
which then alter antigen presentation
there can be
mutations in jack-2 and stat which
can lead to impaired interferon
signaling and there can be up-regulation
of when
in tgf beta which will increase
inhibitory
t-reg cells
and of course the the gut microbiome
can and does play a role in ms
stable colorectal cancers
the the bacterium fuso bacterium
nucleotide will increase the
proliferation of the cancer
and will increase the metastatic cascade
in msi high cancers it will impair t
cell mediated responses such that there
is
less of an immune response when
this is this dominates the gut
microbiome
micro instability is also
closely manifested with angiogenesis
this is looking at 80 patients with
liver metastatic colorectal cancer
and what was noted in the
serum in the blood was increase in
endothelial projector cells
vascular genesis and in the serum
increased veggie f
levels such that that immediately
opens up a treatment avenue of anti-vegf
therapy but it is also important to
know that the death plays a role in the
cancer immune cycle
such that if vegf is markedly elevated
there will be an inhibition of
infiltration of
t cells and tumors thus you can
utilize anti-vegf therapy to drive t
cells into the tumor
there's also a different molecular
makeup of msi high cancers
this is looking at colorectal cancers
from the large
memorial salon kettering database and
what they found in the ms stable
patients that the incidence
of tarpaul fusion was only
0.4 however in the msi high
population it was 5 and some studies
even as high as 7 so any msi high cancer
needs to be assessed for a targetable
fusion
such as intra alp and ros1
because their therapeutic outcome and
impact
is radically different compared to
standard therapy
if there is a targetable fusion there
will be a very poor response sustained
chemotherapy
in this cultural population the median
survival
went from nearly three years to just
15 months and now we know that if you
can target the fusion
that may well exceed what would be
a median overall survival and even going
on for four to
four to five years
unique tumor biology of msi cancers does
lead to a unique treatment response
a decade after msi was identified
it was clear that msi high cancers did
not
get much if any in fact maybe a
detriment
benefit to juventus chemotherapy
it was also known that msi high cancers
tended to do better
but just no benefit of adjuvant
chemotherapy
and this was really demonstrated in the
magic trial
where adding chemotherapy therapy was a
detriment to survival with msi
patients this was in the gastric cancer
pre and post-op chemotherapy those who
had surgery alone
the msi high status does better
that that is much better than the ms
stable patients
and conversely if those patients
received
chemotherapy their outcome is horribly
poor
now this may be a post hoc analysis but
it's not stratification
it is unique tumor biology that does
very poorly with
chemotherapy it is also clear
and suggested from the from the
pre-clinical data
that anti-vegf therapy and particularly
with the prototype bevicism map can do
very well
when added to chemotherapy and can
overcome the
the detriment this is looking at
metastatic colorectal
cancer comparing bevacizumab plus
chemotherapy versus cytosimab
with chemotherapy and in the ms stable
patients there was no difference but
the msi high patients there was a
dramatic
improvement when bevacizumab would add
to chemotherapy
nearly doubling the median overall
survival compared to
cetux map with msi high
even in the adjuvant setting there can
be a benefit of
bevacizumab now the standard of care in
the adjuvant setting is bevacizumab
is not effective but in this particular
study
of the nsabp c08 of of
modified full fox for the adjuvant
setting of resected colorectal cancer
adding bevacizumab no benefit in the ms
stable
population but in the msi high patients
there was a a significant
improvement of curability by adding
bevacizumab to the adjuvant chemotherapy
overcoming the detriment of chemotherapy
and enhancing
the benefit again
this is post hoc but again it's not
stratification it is
treating the unique tumor biology
it was five years ago where
immunotherapy
really exploded across the multitude of
solid tumors
and it was because the understanding
and then the development of monoclonal
antibodies
and the understanding was that the
there are immune checkpoints which put
the brakes on
our immune system ctla-4
plays a role in priming of the t
cell and thus it blocks that priming
but with the monoclonal antibody if the
lipid map that can
block the block therefore t cell priming
can occur
and in the tumor micro environment
there's a pdl1
pd1 barrier pdo1 on the tumor cell pd1
on the t
cell that will block the immune system
leaving the t
cell unable to recognize the cancer in
an exhausted state and therefore could
not
eradicate the cancer but we now have the
capabilities
of the monoclonal antibody inhibitors
for
both pdl-1 and npd1
such that that can remove the breaks and
a person's immune system
can recognize and kill a cancer
and two decades after msi high status
was identified in 2015
that that has come about this was a
study published in the new
journal medicine 2015 looking at
mismatched repair deficient
thus msi high versus proficient ms
stable
cancers responding to an anti-pd1
blockade after progressing on
chemotherapy
this was so impressive along with five
other single arm
multi cohort trials with an overall
response rate of 40 percent
such that the fda granted accelerated
approval
the pimbrolizumab an anti-pd1 monoclonal
antibody
for any solid tumor
that was msi high that had progressed on
prior treatment this was the fda's first
approval based upon what
not the tissue or the anatomical origin
of the cancer but it was tissue
agnostic it didn't matter what cancer it
was
if there was the msi high tumor biology
the
fda approved therapy in that setting
in 2018 there was another fda
approval based upon combining
anti-ctla-4 and anti-pd1
therapy with dual immune checkpoint
blockade
and notably 75 of these patients that
had
two or more prior treatments and had
progressed
overall response rate was 55 percent
an early survival of 70 percent at the
two-year mark in chemotherapy
progressed cold colorectal cancer such
as
the fda approved the combination of the
volamab and epileptomath for msi high
colorectal cancer
now in 2020
and as much turmoil 2020 has brought
all of us the advances in cancer
medicine
really have continued to march
on such that patients with cancer can
live longer
and live better now in 2012
based upon keynote 177 presented at asco
2020
first line immunotherapy was approved
for msi high
colon cancer over and better than
chemotherapy this was a single-agent
anti-pd-1 monoclonal antibody
compared to standard of care
chemotherapy
the response rate was better at 44
compared to 33 percent overall survival
is premature but based upon the dramatic
improvement in progression-free survival
and the durability of response immune
therapy response can be very durable
because of the immune system whereas
chemotherapy responses
are hardly ever durable but based upon
that
front line immunotherapy and msi high
colon cancer it was also
known with the experience with
immunotherapy that it works better
frontline
and it likely works better in earlier
stage disease because there's
less diversity of the neoantigens when
before there is overt metastatic disease
and thus there well could be a window of
opportunity in earlier stage
msi high cancers
and with this particular study
it it looked at msi high status in early
stage and late stage
across the spectrum and the blue was
early stage
the red was late stage and there's
more blue than than red thus
msi high can be more present in earlier
stage
across all cancers that's such that
testing for msi high status should be
done in
all cancers and really across
all stages because of the dramatic
impact
it has on the therapy and the outcome
and this was put to test with earlier
stage
immunotherapy treatment in
colorectal cancers and of the 20
patients who were msi high that received
the dual immune checkpoint blockade and
no chemotherapy
19 to 20 had a major pathologic response
such that over 90 tumor kill
and 12 60 out of the 20 treated
there was no cancer seen when the
patients went to
surgery after immune therapy
msi the msi high tumor biology
clearly chemotherapy is not effective
and
seems to be detrimental clearly
anti-vegf therapy
is is effective and can center and can
undo the detriment of of chemotherapy
and it also can play a role in immune
therapy
and immune checkpoint blockade is very
effective
however only 40 to 50 percent respond
and half
don't receive a benefit but what still
as a medical oncologist
still gives me goosebumps is every time
a person responds to
immune therapy this particular
individual in october 2018
extensive metastatic cancer just with
two months of immune therapy
the cancer is no longer seeable on the
pet imaging
on this individual this is a metastatic
melanoma
that just shows the power of of
immunotherapy
extensive metastatic disease
with immunotherapy a complete response
with the
with the one blush and the left ankle
just being and
ulcerated cutaneous metastases
and what is so dramatic is
that the immune therapy does nothing
directly to the cancer
chemotherapy will directly treat a
cancer radiation directly treats a
cancer
surgery removes a cancer immune therapy
does nothing directly to the cancer but
it will allow a person's own immune
system
to treat the cancer the same immune
system that allow the cancer to
develop in the first place a person's
immune system
is now getting rid of the cancer
but even with all of the the dramatic
advances we're seeing
in this transformative era of cancer
medicine on both molecular precision
oncology and immunotherapy the testing
needs to be done
to identify the best treatment
and it's not getting done
this was from the national cancer
database
looking at young patients with
colorectal cancer which had immediately
sparked
a high risk and concern for lynch
syndrome
based upon the number of nodes which
should not make any difference at all if
there were
greater than 12 nodes examined at the
time of surgery
lynch syndrome msi high testing was
being undertaken
if there were less than 12 oh only a
quarter
so at best 50 and across the board
probably
three and four are not getting
sufficiently tested
and the barrier is the insufficient
tissue sample
to run the test tissue acquisition is
the biggest
barrier and thus the tremendous
treatment benefits
are missed but tissue also has
other limitations there is
inter-tumor and intra-tumor
heterogeneity and a tissue biopsy gets
one side at one point in time
this was a study of ihc stat
standing for mmr status and smsi high
at the primary side and then at a
metastatic site
and of the patients who were msi high in
their primary tumor
20 percent of the time they were ms
stable
in the metastatic tumor and the tumor
mutational
burden reflected that in the msi high
primary
tmb high and ms stable tmb
not high
there's also clonal evolution that
that's all
that is ongoing this was a study
of 24 cases of ovarian cancer
looking at the ones that were
microsatellite stable
after five to six cycles of cisplatin
chemotherapy
when those residual tumors were
reassessed all went from ms stable
after chemotherapy to msi high
and looking at mlh1 staining
it went from positive to undetectable
with epigenetic violencing in 73
of patients there is clonal evil
evolution
going on at metastatic sites
as well as with treatment
and then this
these images just reflect this is just
looking at k-ras and colorectal cancer
it may not be there but then there will
be clonal evolution and selective
pressure
allowing certain clones to grow and then
it can go
it can go back so a cancer is always
changing across the metastatic sites
and across therapies
now everything we know about msi high
cancers and treatment has been based
upon
the standard of tissue testing
but the cancer is always changing a
biopsy at one point in time at one side
is not going to fully reflect
the evolving tumor biology and what we
are already seeing with plasma in
ngs with ct dna it's not
tissue plasma should be the same there
is shedding and non-shedding
and the more aggressive clone that's
circulating
is the is a dynamic clone that needs to
have the aggressive treatment not
necessarily purely the static clone
that is not metastasizing and why should
we not expect that
with msi high status
the liquid biopsy technology
from medical ecologist standpoint really
came
came alive at the 2016 asco meeting
with liquid biopsies focusing on not
circulating tumor cells
but circulating tumor dna and now
now rna and expanding capabilities
the beauty of a liquid biopsy it's
non-invasive
easy to obtain it can be easily repeated
there can be real-time
monitoring of treatment response and
tumor biology evolution
with resistance it's quick and it can
overcome the tissue
epigenetic and and we now have
the capability of testing msi with
liquid biopsies
with liquid biopsies you just get a
whole new view
of a tumor into a tumor biology
and once there's a new technology you
start seeing things differently
then you have to think differently you
have to understand differently
so that you can do differently
the new thermal fisher true
mark msi assay has
made it easier than ever testing for msi
status of cancers
it is an expanded 13 msi marker
panel beyond the bethesda five marker
panel there's no requirement for a
normal tissue for
full in interpretation there can be a
low
well although only a low input of dna is
is needed
thus it can be utilized on circulating
tumor dna
it compares right on par with the
standard ihc
tissue testing with a sensitivity of 92
percent
specificity of 97 and
it can also be utilized when there's low
mutant allele fractions
this is a study we did at circular gene
it was presented at the aacr meeting in
2019 and it
tested liquid msi across
nearly 400 cancers dominated
half were lung cancer but a variety of
other cancers
and what we found at liquid msi
was high in 27 of
the patients when we looked at the east
carolina
university lung cancer
cohort we found that 18
of the lung cancer patients were liquid
msi high
but parallel tissue microsatellite
stable again the dynamic aggressive
clone
can be and frequently is different than
than the static clone
and we noted that three patients went
from msi high
nemas stable to msi high
when they recurred now this is certainly
seeing
things that were not seen with tissue
why the 27 percent why the 18 percent
why why why changing but when you begin
to see things differently you
you observe you think
you ask why and then you adjust and when
you see
these findings you you begin to need to
question
exactly what what is going on that needs
to be studied in a completely different
manner
even with the excitement of of immune
checkpoint blockade
with upfront immune checkpoint blockade
and
msi high colorectal cancers the 44
response rate is better than
chemotherapy but that still means
half of the patients do not respond and
29
had a re had rapidly progressing
disease why is that what can be done
to prevent that from happening
what can be done to keep elevating the
progression free survival and not
and not settling just for the 44
response rate
the the different co do make a
difference
normally a b raf v600e
colorectal cancer has a very aggressive
tumor biology
but in the msi high setting
immunotherapy was equally effective the
b raf b-raf wild-type
yet the k-ras and in-rats mutated
colorectal cancers
had no benefit of immune therapy in fact
the hazard ratio somewhat favored
chemotherapy so co-mutations matter
this is a study that combined the msi
high
status with tumor mutation burden
and those that were both msi high and
tmb
high had this ongoing early but ongoing
100 survival with metastatic colorectal
cancer
so that is a proof of principle that
that that high of a curve
is possible but then why
those that were tamed below
did not do very well at all
and looking at the responders those that
had responded were tmv high those that
were not with tmb
low but it's a matter of identifying
those that are going to be at the 100
and then understanding why everybody is
isn't there and the liquid msi
high is it's going to be a way to
really understand what's going on in the
metastatic setting
and guide therapy
but we now know from the experience with
plasma ngs
and and circulating tumor dna this is
looking at
at patients over 400 patients advanced
cancers
standard of care treatment
what was i identified which was a
seminal
understanding not known or before
or liquid biopsies was that 20 to 30
of cancers won't shed any dna and those
cancers do
much much better the median overall
survival
21 months but it was also clear that the
number of ct dna
alterations doesn't matter whether it's
targetable or not
but any any dna
mutation from the tumor that was
circulating
the number was very prognostic of the
tumor biology aggressiveness such that
if you had
five or more you ct dna mutations
your median overall survival was only
five
months
and then this immediately sparks
a point of study of combining msi high
status and the number of mutations the
numbering mutations do they need
a diff different therapy and why not
adding chemotherapy
with that that's the standard to care
and and then lung cancer
chemo and anime and then an msi high
at ending bev should also play play a
very big role liquid msi high can now
also monitor
immune therapy response this is a small
study
but a a seminal study in in the sense
that you can seriously monitor
monitor liquid msi high and
if it disappears and this is with single
agent
immune therapy when it disa it
disappeared in six
out of the seven responders don't know
about the the durability and
the the one that it did not
clear yet responded but when it
persisted
all with progression all progressed
when it persisted this study
duplicated that looking at the baseline
plasma msi high
status there was a much better outcome
with
with immune checkpoint blockade as as
expected
but liquid just as predictive as tissue
but when two consecutive time points
had zero percent of residual msi
high alleles on treatment there was no
recurrence
those that it did not clear
recurred and b is just looking
at some timelines of the msi
versus radiographic imaging the msi
status disappeared
much much much earlier than the
radiographic improvements
occurred yet the radiographic
improvement did ultimately occur
for tending a complete response
there's also a vital importance
of msi high testing
because it can identify the lynch
syndrome
and the the lint syndrome prevalence
across msi high status 16
of msi high cancers will
have be part of the germline lync
syndrome
which has dramatic importance for their
treatment
but also screened for other cancers as
well as
their family members and
an msi high cancer regardless of the
cancer subtype
should prompt genetic assessment for the
evaluation of a lynch syndrome
this was an editorial in the
in the jco precision oncology just
looking
at the ngs sequencing for msi
and it has been postulated that as many
as 1.2
million individuals in the united states
carry a gene associated flint syndrome
and the 95
of these individuals are unaware of it
therefore msi testing is not only
important for precision
medicine detecting those individuals who
might benefit from immunotherapy in all
cancers because it is
tissue agnostic but also for precision
health
detecting those individuals who are
predisposed
to developing cancer
i certainly don't pretend to have all
the answers
or even know all of the questions but we
can't let the limitations of tissue
limit what liquid msi testing can
identify and see
i can only give my perspective as a
medical oncologist
but it will take a new translational
cancer research approach of more than
just pre-clinical
and clinical translation but when you
have a new technology you have
a triangle and every piece of
information from that new technology
may well be seen just as in liquid msi
seeing things
that we did not know before and that
needs to be fully studied
to continue to help
individuals with cancer live longer live
better and continue to elevate the
right side of cancer survival
durability curve we are clearly far
smarter together than each of us
alone thank you
certainly eager to take any questions on
what you have thank you dr walker for
that informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
what is the difference in turn around
time between
ffpe and liquid biopsy sample types
for msi testing compared to ihc
jennifer there's a lot of issues with
tissue
testing that can be a barrier just as
the one
survey i identified that half of the
time
not performed even though it was needed
because of
tissue acquisition there has to be
sufficient
tissue it can't be used up with the
pathologist
going through their algorithm to try to
label the the cancer of where it came
from
and it really doesn't matter where a
cancer came from
it's what is the tumor biology and this
is what
msi high identifies a unique
that then your treatment based upon the
tumor biology another issue with with
the turnaround time with with tissue
is if a person has a recurrent cancer
put biopsy
it really can cause a pain
complication and oftentimes you don't do
it
so you make a treatment decision that
ends up being the wrong treatment
decision
and the turnaround time can be the same
what you once you once you get it but
getting it becomes
something you can't control where the a
liquid biopsy
getting a blood draw can be
you can pulse back within a week
and then know what's going to be the
best
treatment for your patient and as we
know with msi high
there's a lot of treatments that are the
wrong treatment so the turnaround time
is consistently a week or less with the
liquid biopsy
tissue there are things you you do not
control
and you may not even get it at all
okay well thank you for that
i have another question here your
results
highlighted liquid biopsy showed more
samples with
msi high status could you please speak
more about sensitivity
how is liquid biopsy msi testing more
sensitive
than ffpe based msi testing
that is just part of the evolving
understanding of the new technology of
liquid
things that we never even knew before
a tissue biopsy is it's one
one small part at one
and it does not reflect the overall
intra-tumor
and inner tumor heterogeneity and you
can biopsy it
and on at the distant metastatic sites
and i think it's becoming clear with
plasma ngs
across the board that as you see things
you realize
it's the metastatic clone it's the
metastatic tumor biology
that you want to be treated isaiah
fiddler from
from in md anderson was sort of a
pioneer in our understanding
of of the metastatic process and if you
can identify
that's exactly exactly what you
want to do think what we're beginning to
see
more and more is there it's a different
compartment
of cancer that are confined and
settled in is
what is evolving in the metastatic
cascade
and that's what you want to target it's
still
one of the
answers on exactly what is is going on
but it
that we did not expect at all because
tissue
was felt to be though the the absolute
gold standard
and the little tissue is not the gold
standard
and really the the liquid the
the nts and the circulating tumor dna
and rna
that's the gold standard of what's
really going on
in in in the tumor biology and it's just
one of those many things
we need to understand to treat patients
better so
they can live better and live longer
okay excellent third question here
why is it important that we look at more
markers for msi
analysis more than the five markers on
the bethesda panel
means that we don't want to limit we
this is we don't want to limit our
thanking
the tissue only because of all of the
limitations there
we also don't want to limit our thinking
that something was developed over two
decades
ago in just one particular tumor type in
colorectal
cancers we now know that since
msi high is tissue
what anatomical origin of the cancer is
it is the biology and it's something
that
cancer will have a unique a unique
fingerprint that makes
an other msi eye cancers
so and we know there's there's a
3 million msi loci across our genome
and then you get a panel
then gs panel that will be and they'll
be over 2 000 and then you narrow it
down you keep nailing it down
but you want to keep expanding it so
that you don't miss
a micro satellite
of chemotherapy and and it's something
different msi and then you throw in
you just said as the keynote 177 study
emphasizes yes a good bit for 44
but what about the other 56 and it may
well be
that there are certain low side that can
better predict
an immune response and they're obviously
msi high half of the time they're
knowing who's really going to get the
benefit
based upon their msi high status and
potentially
the the marker and the low side being
an immune biomarker and those that
aren't you you're
those groups of indiv individuals were
radically
different so it's just something that
you identify the better the information
that you can enrich the group subset
that's going to get
a dramatic benefit and then you
and enhance those that need more
treatment than just
single agent immune checkline
okay thank you okay here we go there's
another question coming in
when would you recommend asking for a
liquid biopsy
instead of ffpe tumor tissue at first
chance
as everything is evolving with liquid
biopsies
it is becoming clear that they
are they are complementary
that you can get some information from
tissue
and some information you can get more
information from
liquid getting both
is always the ideal because we're
talking about identifying
different compartments based upon how
many metastatic sites there are how are
you going to biopsy every metastatic
site
now you really want the sum of what the
biology is
and our approach we would always
liquidate tissue parallel well knowing
half of the time
tissue to get everything that
get the information here
we'll make the best
blind because with msi high cancers if
you just blindly
go with enter to care chemotherapy
that's going to be very detrimental on
on things
something that upon recurrence every
time a cancer progresses
there will be clonal the cancer is
always
changing you don't want to make
treatment decisions
based upon the cancer that's not the
active
clone that that is is undergoing the
metastatic
process and it's always changing
with with resistance just like in that
cancer population anybody that was in
stable after cis flat when they were
re-biopsy
tip of any what the residual disease and
residual resistant clones were msi high
and it's something that with the liquid
biopsy
as with everything we sort of started in
metastatic disease and
then you end up working back and now we
know two things there
you want to be able to monitor that over
time
and therefore repeating the liquid
biopsy provides you far better in
information than sometimes
and oftentimes repeating scans i'm not
advocating not repeating scans
but clear clearly time and time again a
liquid biopsy
can identify things better identify
things
earlier and even the very fact of
clearing the msi
status in in the blood is is a very very
very good predictive indicator and
whereas if you don't
you clearly need you will clearly need
something different
and and another thing that is evolving
is if
msi high is actually more frequent
than earlier stage disease the utility
of msi high in early stage disease
where you even get your cure
benefit just as in that one neoadjuvant
study with a 60
pathologic complete response
dual immune checkpoint blockade msi high
colorectal cancer
60 of the time no cancer
seen now now that was with surgery but
but ultimately
liquid may even we're not not there yet
but things are rapidly evolving and we
that's why the understanding and the
thinking has to
has to be rapidly evolving that you may
not even need surgery if you would clear
potentially
potentially clear your msi high on on
things so
it's just something that getting a
liquid biopsy provides so much
information at every
every point in time for the best
treatment decision that
that you can make where
tissue you end up not getting it and
then you don't know it and then you make
the wrong step
okay we have time for one more question
let's see here
what are adequate criteria for liquid
biopsy
and how frequent is false negative when
tumor burden is very low
that is also one of the evolving
understandings initially it was okay
plasma has to be concordant to
tissue but that was sort of old thinking
now it's clear that certain cancers
will shed more ct dna and rna than
other cancers those cancers that
mutations clearly have a higher tumor
burden
it's evolving that it's clearly a more
cancer just as that one
shedding any ctd in the metastatic
setting
the median overall survival was it was
really
with 21 months plus but it was only
six months if if you were if you were
shedding so
you're not going to get a a false
negative in the sense that it's negative
and it's falsely negative it's just
shedding
and non-shedding still actionable
in on on things and and also why tissue
and plasma are still going to be
complementary that if you're not
shedding ct dna
and your your liquid msi is negative
that's actually
a much better potential
situation because you've already cleared
your msi high
and you you will like you you clearly
will
do better so even information that's not
directly
targetable is always actionable from
from
liquid these begin to understand in
particular the shetty non-shedding
biology concept
okay great um i would
like to thank the audience first of all
for joining us today
we would like to get your input about
the presentation and questions about
your current msi workflow in a moment
you'll see some survey questions
if you'd please take a moment to add
your input to the poll we would greatly
appreciate it
dr walker do you have any final comments
for the audience
the final comment is all of this the
whole msi
the the pre-clinical work with the
clinic that was the old translational
of cancer research now we have
with the new technology now it's sort of
a triad and when we need to
we need to work together to keep going
forward because it's not just a matter
of of information it's a matter of
patients lives
that that all of this is for
patients because it matters
yes okay thank you again dr walker for
your time today and for your really
important research
we would like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye